uh just quick hand anyone involved with
the ml here like anyone that were okay
great fantastic fantastic so yeah so I'm
going to say I'm just trying to uh
I was trying to teach myself this stuff
a couple few years
um I work in a company that that deals
with like low latency serving for ads
unfortunately and I am
I am I've seen many uh iterations of
products along the years past like seven
years
um
I mean I never you know it never stops
improving or getting worse but here I
try to really write down kind of what
the internet thinks uh is ml latency
techniques reduction techniques so let's
let's dive into it right so the the
first PSA that I want to leave you with
is that you want to focus on the latency
of your ml models if you are serving mm
models live to some customers
you know that's the first thing that
they're gonna see and the many teams uh
forget this PSA and then uh they
discover too late that uh that their
models are not uh responding fast enough
and so you lost you know six months of
of valuable time
so what will you get from this talk this
stock first I want you to understand uh
you know low leads in serial time
what what kind of options you have and
just a map of thinking about it uh you
get to sound smart with your product
managers you get to save yourself time
you don't lose hope and Engineering
comes and tells you you know you know we
can't we can't help you deploy this
because it's too slow
and your products might succeed who
knows you know
um so I you know I try to put this in a
pictures right I think most like
generalization like very visual people
um I have like two maps one is the data
flow patterns that I've seen happening
over the years and then a common
abstraction layers so this is on my blog
post I have blog post about this we're
just gonna go down the the list just to
motivate you to read it or to to look at
the references I don't expect you to you
know remember everything I've said today
uh
mostly just enjoy the flow just get a
sense of what's happening over the
so basically what do we say we have the
not so rare case of excessive ml agency
so things that that can
um
they're like symptoms of uh of low
latency ml uh use cases is that the
cutoff is really like 100 milliseconds
everything above it is offline I I call
it the fly it's a 100 millisecond a bar
below humans
um consumption of information really
they
something takes longer than 100
milliseconds for some reason you know
they lose interest so you lost the
customer
so you so that's like the core kind of
idea there uh during the the
optimization of this you need to figure
out you need to learn this nice concept
of optimizing versus satisfying sin
satisficing metric uh you know
optimization
you need to to realize that you're going
to be dealing with like low latency read
databases a lot
and then we're going to talk about
pre-computing and caching tooling
okay so the common abstraction layers
that I found so far uh not that I found
that I collected so far uh is really
this this this tree of information so we
are here right ml agency we're gonna go
down this little tree of knowledge
together so first thing that that data
scientists whenever they join you know
year one month one it's like they
learned that that that uh they they're
training you know I don't say like
they're trained but like 80 percent of
their of their training is based on this
pipeline
this pipeline is you have a data
warehouse
you have some pre-processing jobs you
pre-process the data to make it
consumable by the scoring jobs and then
you store the score data and you make it
available in some sort of uh database
that that consumers can can hit whenever
they need
but those consumers expect a database
response they don't expect a low latency
ml systems so this is like you know 80
percent of the training that data
scientists get
but in the online world right in the
online world it's like you have this
real-time generation of recommendations
online ranking uh prediction of a
critical piece of equipment will fail
sharp medical devices that are like you
know doing like knee surgery you really
want to be quick to to detect problems
grocery time
so inside the the the the online world
you have two two types right you have
the synchronous asynchronous
asynchronous is divided in two parts
right I don't know what happened to my
pictures but it doesn't matter there are
a little bit a little bit
sick so you have push and pull right so
like when you are when you are having
asynchronous interaction
um you know you have two ways either you
push in information so so the caller
goes like hey I have this logged in user
she's she's actively but uh active she's
currently active but messing with her
subscription settings should we send her
a new retention promotion email before
she quits our amazing service model say
let's let me think about it I'll send
you a push notification if we need then
you wait time passes and then the caller
says you know send this promotion for
three free meals
this is the push method the pull method
is the color itself is hey I have this
logged in user let me think about it and
then the colors like any news and then
using in using and using news okay let's
incentivize them so those in the
asynchronous world asynchronous
pipelines if I had to summarize it right
like
it's a little bit too much but but you
you know you you have a client up top
um it hits a prediction API prediction
API submits stuff to to uh to request
events there is some event processing
and you you it hits an event scoring uh
system passes the scored events back to
the to some messaging system and then
you have two options to collect
information and give it back to the
client so this is asynchronous like you
know you don't you don't expect too much
trouble
but when you are like dealing with
synchronous online prediction that's
when the pain kind of really shows up
and it shows up
because now
you have you have the ml API is is a you
know a rest API grpc some sort of API
that you expected to respond right away
in like less than 10 milliseconds for
example
and the model generates prediction sends
it back to the color and if the model if
the if you run out of latency budget
then you say to the customer you know
prediction took too long try later we
lost the customer right so you you're uh
you have this concept of timeout that's
just gonna that's your budget that's how
long you're willing to wait
but for for uh the it's almost like the
performance profile of this uh
synchronous apps
sometimes you know new data scientists
they think that it's just the model but
in fact it's the you know you have
pre-processing of the enriching input
requests generating the prediction
process processing and then you have a
bunch of security encoding that slows
down the traffic load balancing Auto
scaling number of components you know
you it's lots of fun
so how do we deal with this synchronous
world right so we're here right so
synchronous production predictions
the the big thing that's uh that's nice
to keep in mind for synchronous is that
you can split them into two parts right
split them into the construction of the
prediction and the serving of the
prediction
and the big realization and lots of lots
of ml engineers get right away is that
is that only so much can be done to
optimize the model right you you can
remove supporting components you can
mess with core components
but uh but so getting rid of supported
model component is like the first thing
that happens like oh I have extra
logging extra metrics monitoring uh
debugging helpers all that all that goes
away right you you can remove them as
long as you have some testing embedded
in the in the code so you know that you
didn't break anything but the but the
real key to to optimize this sorts of
systems is what is is realizing that you
are not just in the optimization offline
world where you're optimizing some sort
of like you know
uh map mrr accuracy precision log loss
those metrics are great in the offline
world
and any new you know higher high lower
lows are great winning offline world but
you need to realize that you have a
satisficing metric that you need to to
uh to take care of is uh will it fit in
the model will the model fit in the
device that I'm that um that's at the
edge or uh do we do I require special
chips uh can the feature processing
finish within time bounds
and then the model latency of course now
this this
you know like you you see people you see
you know new newcomers focusing on
optimizing metrics uh so you you end up
ignoring the satisfying metrics so
satisfying metrics some things like if
you want to speed up latency of your
model at the model construction at the
prediction construction apart what you
do uh you can specify a smaller model
you can have a lower number of features
can do sparsify when possible on the
model itself you can trim the number of
trees you can trim the number of trees
in a random forest in gradient boosting
trees uh you know smaller layers in a
neural network a smaller number of
variables in a logistic regression
but all of this needs needs some sort of
method so the method that you want to
use is that you set the satisfying
metric to something that's business
related our customers will give up on
our product and go to our competitor if
we don't serve this prediction with less
than 10 milliseconds for example and
then you keep increasing the complexity
of the model
which hopefully increases the you know
the the evaluation metric that you're
using until you get really close to the
to the satisficing metric
again so if you have two options here if
the model latency meets the requirement
but the predictive Effectiveness is too
low you keep increasing the complexity
but if the model latency is too high uh
and uh and then then then you need to
um you know it's like a it's like a and
you can't achieve the predictive
requirement
then it's a business uh kind of decision
like you can't really the business needs
to adapt you cannot force a business to
use a slow model just because offline is
great
so that's something that's a nice little
method of doing
so the second PSA is that you want to
realize that 10 model local latency
construction boost will get crushed by
distributed i o so as soon as you're you
know you think that's you know you're
you're your local laptop model or you
know whatever training infrastructure
you're using
um
is uh is is great oh yeah like uh I can
do you know two milliseconds whatever
like uh
Improvement or to my model
um
as soon as you're gonna hit distributed
IO you're gonna run into trouble so why
are you gonna hit distribute to die
right so it's in the serving part so we
looked at the construction part but in a
serving part you have two parts you have
the model inputs model outputs right
so the features in the model inputs are
pretty much the whole operation the
whole time sync that you're gonna have
to deal with all right so they come in
three three flavors this is like part of
the mental model that I try to keep in
mind uh you have user supplied features
static reference features and then
Dynamic real-time features
you know they some things come directly
from the request some some things are
like historical values that you can
pre-calculate and then Dynamic reads and
features like what did the customer do
in the past five minutes
so the easy case right the easy case is
when you have uh every ml Gateway around
will be asking for this sort of query I
need a single row with one column for
each of the features of entity X
so you have you have this usage
optimization
um but then the the you know the I guess
the third realization is that new
newcomers
they're like okay I have this great data
warehouse uh you know the terabytes of
data
are loaded in there I can do
aggregations I build my training sets
everything is great but at serving time
the latency for data warehouses that's
not what you want right
so so that that ends up being
you so you're a data scientist that's a
large corporation or like small startup
and then you you have to do this all
right periodically extract the simple
and aggregated features and place them
in a data store optimized for single key
lookup operation so that
immediately
slows you down I mean in terms of
product development because you have to
talk to a to some external team like a
data engineering team that will help you
do this because it's not in your core
competencies
so you want to budget for that time in
terms of development
but what does it look like in a picture
right so in a picture you you start
seeing that there's going to be two two
things happening separately in the
offline world right we have the the data
warehouse feature set and then you have
these batch jobs that are going to be
crucial to your success and there you're
going to load them in a in a low latency
uh static feature storage
and now the the ml Gateway uh becomes
kind of critical because it is
responsible for getting a client entity
ID or like a customer ID
looking up the the attributes for this
for this entity static features that we
have
and then giving it to the ml model for
scoring and then returning it to the
client so it's a little bit of a dance
this ml Gateway becomes more and more
important for your latency requirements
overall you know still feasible right
it's invisible uh so the less easy case
in Dynamic real-time features is when
you are trying to use not historical
averages or historical uh stats you what
you want is like what happened in the
past a few kind of uh you know few
interactions with your product or you
have some sort of Warehouse with
Machinery that's that's making some
cookies and you're like you know which
one has where is the butter is going to
melt to too quickly and it's gonna start
a fire
and so you want you you're collecting
information pretty quickly so in this in
this next diagram uh you have two inputs
you have the event Zapped up
and then you have the clients that are
trying to get a prediction on the bottom
so the core part of this machinery
is that now you're gonna have uh you
know the events coming so that's like
the time series that are happening or
sorts of events that are happening
they're going to come in an event
processing system
even processing system is gonna try to
do real-time feature engineering feature
transformation and then store the
features themselves in a low latency
feature store
and and at the same time as soon as
there is new data and enough data to to
make a prediction uh the the model API
is going to get involved so you are
pre-calculating the model the the
predictions and storing them in some
output database
and what happens is that the ml Gateway
now is constantly waiting for a request
from the client and that you know you
pick up the the predictions from the
from the read uh low latency read
prediction store
and return them to the client and then
uh you know you don't live in an
isolated world so you're like I need to
also publish it to some Downstream
consumers of this thing in another
messaging system so it gets a little bit
more complicated right we have messaging
systems we have event processing load
latency for features and low latency for
for uh predictions
it's a little bit a little bit strange
so this is just a described what would
just happen
so that's for the model inputs right
model inputs you have this Branch here
where you were you can handle various
strategies
on the on the bottom side you have model
outputs what do you do with model
outputs so you have so once you have a
prediction right if if all the
techniques covered so far do not make
your prediction latest low enough then
you need to pre-compute and cache the
the predictions
to do that
the basic flow right the basic flow is
the same right you you have a you have a
client upped up ML Gateway an ml Gateway
just expects the predictions to be
already pre-calculated
and on the on the bottom side are you
offline data batch processing prediction
that puts in a periodic updates
so what kind of challenges do you face
there when you try to pre-compute your
predictions is that you have uh a
problem with lookup keys so lookup Keys
become critical if either you you're in
a use case where entities are are okay
right you have a domain entity
or you need to rely on a combination of
feature values
things like uh you know location current
shopping carts segments information
products category things that are going
to be more anonymous
which is sometimes required and you you
need to specify what's this feature
combination look like all right so
you're you're stuck right you're stuck
with with dealing with this entity
cardinality so if you have hundreds of
vehicles that you're monitoring and you
want to predict you know which which
truck is going to break down we need to
stop it or whatever you're you you have
hundreds of vehicles but if you're like
a 100 million catalog that you're trying
to run recommendations on uh the the
entities
cardinality just blows up
so how do you how do you deal with this
right so instead of calculating
predictions for all the entities what
you're gonna do is you're gonna run a
top end kind of most blank entities like
so most interacted with most viewed most
uh some sort of you know some sort of
verb that matters for your business
and then you pray for the rest of the
long tail of Romanian products so it
happens here is that again you have same
story right you have the clients up top
that the toxo model Gateway right model
Gateway checks for the top end entities
and an in-memory output prediction it's
like do we have any predictions for this
for this user for this entity
if we don't have then it checks the
non-frequent entities
in a in a I guess less expensive uh
database kind of uh where you can store
more entities but it's cheaper and then
if not none of those work then you go
for the for the you know you you la you
run a live prediction on your model
okay from the bottom from the bottom you
know same kind of store you you have
batch scoring jobs and then best
training job that uploads models or
uploads uh pre-calculated predictions
so that's for how you do uh
pre-computing the predictions but
remember this is just an example right
you have a combination of values right
like country device type some category
you really want to think about it's a
product of those so you really want to
say I I'm gonna set a cutoff on the top
most you know useful anti uh you know
items that I'm that I want to predict
okay so it's just the I guess the key
here is that you as you're discovering
this domain of of low latency ml you see
you see there's like these jumps in
pricing of the databases that you're
going to be using or the sort of low
latency apis for querying and pushing
data there's like little jumps right
like your
I guess like every cloud provider
provides almost like this three-tier I
don't know why it's like three three
tier right you have like the the cold
cold storage sort of you know we will
return to data whenever whenever we can
then you have the ones that are disk
based but they they say they are low
latency and then you have in-memory uh
kind of uh storage
uh and and then and then that's like the
lowest latency you can get
um and then you
so you want so you know here the joke is
that the the
Financial operations are going to come
to you they're going to be like oh you
know you're you're Bill last last month
was too high
so what do you do again is not only now
you so now you solve somehow the latency
problem
but but you use the same algorithm
between optimizing and satisfies in
metric
to to lower your cost as well so the
cost of your of your infrastructure and
and so so how do you do that right so
you're so you're so you want to reuse
predictions as as efficiently as
possible
we're here now right we're here so to
reuse uh prediction you have two methods
right you have exact match
and you have a proximate matching exact
matches like I have this uh this
this uh product what are the products
that are most that are closest to this
product but I need to return them to the
customer as quickly as possible
so that's uh exact matching like you
know
but then you have a proximate matching
that's that's that will
um they will do something special right
you it it's it's a bit of a
I guess still a research
um
Topic in the ml source of research is
that you're able to to to build this
this embeddings of the products that
um that are features that represent the
product but they keep the distance
uh between products so the any sort of
semantic distance between between two
products will be kept if they are in the
you know real world space close to each
other the the those vectors those
embedding vectors that you generate will
be closed
in the embedding space as well
you know huge Discovery uh it's like
pretty impressive but what you do with
those embeddings is that you drop them
in a in a in a database where you can
build an index on these vectors
uh there's there's a couple uh examples
uh The Annoying Annoying system or scan
and uh are are too uh popular ones
but here what you need to realize is
that you have a model that so you're you
you have your products in your digital
Warehouse right you build embeddings
from that and then you build an index on
those on those products and buildings
but then at request time
you use the same model to generate The
Entity embeddings so that also needs to
be
optimized so that you can calculate the
embeddings pretty quickly
the main concern that happens is like oh
you know what do I do if the index is
too large yeah it's just you know you're
you're you cannot search fast enough you
cannot search fast enough so you you
reduce the embedding size to get a
smaller index
if you can't get the the right mix of
optimizing satisfaction trade out you
just look elsewhere
okay other other tips for low latency
caching of predictions you have things
like you uh you definitely want to
realize that you're gonna have more rows
than columns
and you have if you have high categories
High number of categories have
cardinality categories then you're gonna
have a bad lookup latency for your
features
and obviously baptizing you know is
going to be part of your
that's all you can do really
um so the main method again you lower
the the cardinality and the
satisfiencing metric is okay and
optimizing metric doesn't wind too much
overall
the the summary of this again is to just
give you like an overview right pretty
quick overview of what are the options
available today probably
you know most of them obviously not all
of them but it's most most options right
your your
um
like it's like the work of of an ml
engineer or data scientist probably I'd
say 60 to 70 that's 80 of the time is
going to be in the offline world
and so don't get too complacent there in
the in the in the continuous delivery
kind of aspect of our work
um
you you do want to start with uh they
call it a A Primitive whole right A
Primitive whole system
where where uh you know it's not quite a
full-on uh
system that you want but but but you you
you went all the way from your
experimentation to the serving and back
no matter how bad your uh your uh your
offline metric is
as as
early as possible in the product life
cycle
um you know just reporting like personal
drama uh you know you keep stuff on your
laptop and you're helping data
scientists you know uh optimize optimize
optimize optimize but then but then as
soon as you hit serving you realize that
it's a completely different world so
what you wanna you really want to use
those continuous delivery sort of ideas
where you go all the way you know
comments acceptance performance
conformance you know governance and you
you're at the point where
where you're able to simulate the real
traffic
from the real product that you're going
to be serving without without waiting
too long right then you sound smart save
yourself time and then so I you know
these two maps are pretty useful the
first map that we discussed right we
went from from the offline one number
one you know then you have the async
version
and then you move into the synchronous
world where you're gonna split this this
sort of uh offline online and then you
have the real time uh events processing
as they come in
um
and then you have what kind of
strategies you can use for the for the
caching and pre-computation
I have more detail on my blog post if
you want and then this nice map right
it's nice to keep it in mind right this
is going for your buck on this side and
common abstraction layers we start to
see splits it offline online uh you know
if you need synchronous you need to
split it again construction or serving
and then
I guess I can't like beating a dead
horse but but just don't get stuck here
you know don't get stuck in the
construction for too long uh you you
definitely wanna test out your your um
your latency early on in your in your
product life cycle then you have two two
types like model input model outputs
um
the approximate matching is still
ongoing research so it's kind of nice to
to see that people are gonna come up
with new ideas
um
there is one here that I didn't cover
the authoring and discovering
um it is not you know sometimes DNS is a
it's like a good example of of like
discovering which feature you should be
using
we'll add to your latency so you
definitely want to have some
optimization there
that's pretty much it so I have a couple
uh links here you know blog posts sort
of architecture stuff there's a couple
blog posts that I wrote about uh feature
stores if you're interested uh more da
posts and I have a little book here that
I wrote two years ago clean machine
learning code that's more about like you
know code quality but uh yeah thank you
for your attention
do we have any questions
uh I'm gonna come back there with them
like
thank you so much for sharing all this
um it's a space that I um still learning
more about what I'm curious about is
um
is there ever an approach where you know
your your model that you trust the most
and is is most accurate
um I'm referring to the you know the
caching but then the cash misses and so
forth and
um so is there ever do you ever see an
approach where you have your kind of
your best model but maybe the slower one
um and if it's a cash Miss then of
course you keep track of okay maybe we
need to cash that kind of thing in the
future but for now we'll use like a
faster model that's like it's not quite
as good but it's faster is that an
approach that you see sometimes correct
yeah we've we've seen uh yeah you've
seen it's more it's like your your
collecting information about which so
yes like this diagram here
um
let me find this yeah so this this
diagram here where you're checking for
your cash you know super fast super
duper fast here and if you don't find
them but you notice that you're getting
the same sort of entity or feature combo
uh again right that's that's part of the
that's part of collecting information
about what's you know what kind of
prediction request are you getting and
then you you keep them somewhere right
you and then and then the next time you
want to decide which uh what should be
included in Stop n
um then then you can use that
information to optimize your cash so to
minimize the cache misses that you're
saying but you don't want to just catch
Miss and be like uh you know forget it
you want to do like what the OS does
right you you you go memory if you don't
find it in memory it's in virtual memory
it's going to swap out and then you're
gonna you know you don't want to avoid
like thrashing but that's not
impossible right you you can have
slightly slower uh prediction cash
for uh you know
infrequent predictions but that are kind
of important and the client is is
willing to wait a little bit longer than
the than the general latency timeout
budget but yeah I've seen
yeah
Musa thanks a lot for that wonderful
insightful roadmap
um one quick question that I didn't see
maybe maybe it's embedded in one of
those uh pictures is how do you deal
with an ensemble of models that actually
have a kind of a pipeline that they
might be dealing with both structured
data and as well as unstruct data and
you might want to split up some
prediction to go to the CPU and the
other ones to go to the GPU because
you're doing image inferences or you're
doing segmentation in real time how do
you deal with that because there you
actually have to deal with with latency
now you're actually transferring data to
the to the memory GPU how do you how do
you deal with that correct yeah the the
more generic way of saying it is the I
guess now they call them like model
meshes where you where you you are not
the only modeling team so you're you're
you're uh you know it reminds me of like
uh how insurance
quotes used to be done right you you
have you're a broker and the broker just
sends hey who wants to insure this car
and then you have a bunch of insurance
companies that are expected to respond
but they're competing with each other so
they're competing consumers that's like
uh in the Enterprise Integration
patterns book
from Gregor hope you you you you
definitely want to structure it so that
a lagger uh you know someone that's not
responding fast enough
you know you you have a way to
disqualify them so that you don't have
to to wait for for slow models uh for
multi so so I haven't I gotta say the in
this low latency world I haven't seen
too much
um in the so in the prediction request
that comes in usually it's stripped down
to its minimum it's currently all right
like 2022 you know technology you you're
gonna the the usual predictions that
you're gonna get are gonna be super
stripped down uh so you're not dealing
with you know a huge text huge images
huge videos
you already if you're getting any sort
of those you already pre-calculated the
like a feature Vector for for the video
that you're that you're you're showing
or you are
you're really compressing the video to
to its minimum sorts of features that
are gonna come inside the ml Gateway
um so those are like the two techniques
so you have the competing consumers
pattern
and you have the and the model mesh I
guess those are like two two topics that
that fits with each other and then in
the low latency world you definitely
want to talk to your business
stakeholders tell them the input
features that we can ingest are gonna be
you know just one integer please kind of
but it is it is yeah today right it's
just today
I don't know what the future is going to
bring but
all right we got a couple questions over
here yeah
um uh nice talk I want to give you
thoughts on Technologies like you know
in terms of radius versus Cassandra
versus Cocos de Uno what are the best
ways and also so I did promise myself
not to not to be technologically uh you
know not sell anybody
but but I understand yeah it's so but
but in in you have data warehouse right
you have uh databases that are still
storage based disk based or SSD based
that are that are optimized to to have
some nice lookup uh speed
and then you move into the the
how do you call them the the in-memory
databases
and uh so that's for for like the
storage kind of thing and then in the
messaging part in the messaging part
same thing some some Q some Q some
messaging systems are optimized for
throughput right that's something I
didn't even talk about here right so
like usually it go together right you
have a low latency system with a high
throughput
is very different from a low latency
system with low throughput these these
ideas can be used in both but uh those
are like the the the categories that you
want to use when you're looking at a at
a product like the ones you mentioned
right your your uh yeah so data
warehouse disk basis is the base
database in an immoral store and then
you have messaging systems that are low
latency messaging system and throughput
based messaging systems
uh those in my mind you know it's just
another way to think about it
yeah hi yeah thanks for the talk
um a lot of these Concepts seem to
remind me a lot of just like
microservices architectures in general
how would you say that you know in a
machine learning role that might be
different from you know like Netflix
does a lot of microservice architecture
they have conductor and he's a big
orchestration engines under the hood to
optimize microservice latencies right
how is ml just different yeah it's
amazing right 2022 we still don't have a
good grasp of the the what I what I
would what I would argue for is that uh
if you're if you're managing a low
latency system you definitely want to
keep pretty much everything that you
rely on every dependency inside your
bounded context you do not want to have
um excessive communication
to another bounded context that the
microservice architecture would would
provide you so you you you are you are
like depending on a different team that
that might uh might have a different
release Cadence really like a different
uh I don't know constraints for their
job for their for their tasks uh you
want to
almost like replicate you know if some
if some data engineering team is is
helping you do feature engineering
feature transform it's almost like you
you want to take snapshots inside your
bounded context so you don't have to
rely on unnecessary dependencies but it
it does have a lot to do with this
microservice because you're gonna rely
on a bunch of of teams that are outside
of your control
um you know and
even the networking the you know like if
you're on a cloud provider you you
definitely want to be
not not like an expert but you you want
to know enough about about regions
differences you want to know about uh
the co-location of your services where
they're gonna live
um
but uh yeah so that's what I would say
about the microservice analogy to this
to this challenges I'd say
all right we have about literally one
minute for questions we're going to do
the last one
hi
um you touched on really quickly having
the ability to kind of like log that a
prediction event occurred to some like
messaging service but like that seems
secondary to ultimately getting the the
prediction to the the client in this
case that being the most important
um right how do you or how have you
managed that conversation with the
understanding if you're gonna do logging
in your application there's some
development cycle there versus saying to
the client maybe client you log this
interaction in you know in in terms of
the payload and the response how have
you navigated those conversations
talking about you know how much faster
can make your development cycle or who
that burden should be on
yeah the well yeah it is it is a great
question you know the the the fact that
that you know you you need an ml Gateway
that will orchestrate to some extent
what's happening between you and the
clients is kind of
um I guess not advertised enough that
you don't realize that this American
will be a critical source of future
training data so you that's why I have
like this little like link here where
your your ml Gateway is whatever it gets
whatever prediction it's served you know
it shoves it back to some messaging
system for a downstream consumers which
might end up in the events themselves
but deciding I don't have a good answer
on on this side in you know which
responsibility it is uh my gut feeling
is like you know the the ml engineering
team that's responsible for this
it's a product right you you have inputs
and you have exhaust and if that's
exhaust is valuable then it's part of
your product then you wanna you wanna
own it and provide it as as uh as hooks
to debug to analyze to audit to past
compliance
so I would I would keep it inside the
bonus context again uh but you know it's
it's a deep depends on the case right
yeah
cool
thank you very much thanks everyone